[Music]
my next guest is a two-time ex game gold
medalist for women's motocross and she's
the first deaf person to ever compete
professionally in the sport she'll be
going for her third gold medal in the
upcoming X Games
please welcome along with her father Jim
21 year old Ashley Fiolek Jim you are
here to interpret is that correct yeah
okay
first of all welcome Ashley thanks for
being here thank you for inviting me
here thank you
and I know that I'm very attractive yeah
there was a pause there she's like okay
I'll be nice to Henry this is a
fascinating story first of all your
granddad and your dad grew up racing and
your dad got you started what age we
talking yeah well I started riding
actually when I was three years old and
just I didn't start race until seven
though so they just loved the road with
my dad my grandpa I just loved it so but
what's interesting is that you were
riding a motor you weren't riding a
tricycle when you were three you were
riding a motorized bike pretty young
yeah I never really actually rode a
bicycle I didn't learn how I just always
rode a motorcycle
well then Jim this questions for you
what the heck were you thinking
yeah you know it's it seemed like a good
idea at the time and I just grew up my
dad grew up riding and you know we just
thought when Ashley was born we were
gonna get her a motorcycle and ride and
it just turned into all this yeah okay
your was there a harness was there any
kind of seatbelt was there any kind of I
mean I I can't imagine a three-year-old
on a motorized bike we actually have a
picture here of you this is a little
older but it's still the same gas
powered bicycle is that right which I'd
be afraid to get on that no there's no
no special harness I would hold my dad's
I would hold the crossbar and just go
through the woods and my little PW that
little more so like I would just ride it
head training wheels on it and it it
didn't work real good at first but I
still had fun on it I didn't realize you
could put training wheels on a motorized
bike yeah actually yeah they're actually
they were for a bicycle but we put them
on a motorcycle oh well then that makes
perfect sense